eric zemmour est un homme auquel me lis
une solide amitié et de solides des
accords
comme le montre l'extrait la citation
que vous avez produit notre amitié est
née sur un plateau de télévision on ne
se connaissait pas on a fait
connaissance en direct me souviens très
bien de la scène nous étions à l'époque
c'était on n'est pas couché et on
intervenait seulement en deuxième partie
de soirée nous étions derrière un gradin
et on commence à discuter on ne s'était
jamais parlé l'amitié s'est cristallisé
en deux temps d'abord parce que en plus
de s'opposer on a compris qu'il était
plus marrant de prendre les invités l'un
par sa droite l'impasse à gauche et
ensuite là où je pense que notre amitié
s'est définitivement installée c'est que
eric zemmour a traversé des périodes de
turbulences médiatiques et qu'il était
très content que pendant les cinq ou six
heures d'enregistrement d'on n'est pas
couché ça soit non pas une parenthèse
enchantée le mot est un peu fort mais
une parenthèse un peu allégé il était
content d'oublier ça en plus il a deux
il a le sens de l'humour moi ce que
j'appelle le sens de l'humour c'est
quelqu'un qui est rien mais blake
valérie beaucoup à une blague et on
s'amusait beaucoup mais vous faites pas
de la guérit donc du très bon public
mais il très beau plus c'est un homme
très sympathique et très ouvert
maintenant cette amitié jeune-là
renierai jamais j'étais au meeting
devait quand on vous dit quand on vous
dit je vous dis cela je vous dis ce que
je tombe vous dit vous êtes vous êtes un
homme de gauche vous avez toujours
défendu des idées de gauche comment il
ya des gens je vous ai eu des tweets
disent comment eric naulleau peut être
ami avec un monstre comme eric zemmour
prévu des choses comme ça si vous
répondez être le mot mensonge lors là je
viens d'apprendre qu'il n'appartenait
pas à l'humanité ça fait beaucoup en
quelques secondes un monstre qui
n'appartient pas à l'humanité l'a bien
fait de venir qu'est ce que vous
répondez oui c'est important que vous
nous disiez que je la connais je
m'entends à titre personnel je m'entends
très bien avec eric zemmour voilà pour
la solide amitié nos solides d accord il
suffit d'avoir regardé les émissions que
nous avons fait ensemble c'est pour ce
soir nous avions sans sabrer dans
l'écouté rien que la sq hérité ce
qu'elles étaient évoqués ou ce qu'a dit
eric zemmour au mythique de ville patil
et pour la suppression du droit du sol
je suis contre cette suppression il est
pour la déchéance des binationaux
délinquants je suis contre cette
déchéance il est pas favorable même
défavorable aux passes tony terre je
suis favorable sur l'immigration zéro
vous êtes comme en parlant l'immigration
zéro il ya des tas de choses dans
lesquelles je vais pas d'accord je peux
citer un point d'accord je suis en effet
favorable à l'expulsion des délinquants
étrangers voilà un point le seul point
d'accord peut-être sur l'immigration
eric zemmour a dit qu'il était
philosophiquement favorable à la peine
de mort je suis défavorable physiquement
à la peine de mort je n'accepte pas que
des gens se réunissent pour décider si
un être peut être coupé en deux ou pas
et il ya un autre point c'est peut-être
le plus surprenant mettre sur un sujet
où nos futures ont l'un et l'autre eh
bien ces derniers temps eric zemmour
penche plutôt vers la légalisation du
cannabis alors que moi je suis contre la
légalisation du cannabis voilà donc
aussi c'était une on avait une
discussion
toi comme moi on est assez mou venger
parce que c'est là que j'essaie de
réfléchir là dessus je n'arrive pas à
trouver de bonnes que moi non plus je
change d'avis toutes les semaines mais
les derniers temps eric eric naulleau
c'est votre ami c'est mon ami mais ce
que vous l'avait poussé à se présenter
est-ce que vous en a parlé avant est ce
que vous m'avez dit c'est n'importe quoi
non il n'en a parlé avant j'ai été
associé à tous les stades de sa
réflexion en tant qu'ami absolument pas
en tant que conseiller et je crois pas
trahir un secret il ya eu un basculement
où on sortait ensemble on revenait vers
le métro après l'enregistrement d'une
émission de zemmour et naulleau et il
m'a dit est ce que tu imagines au mois
de mars dans la peau d'un commentateur
et ben ça a été le basculement pour moi
parce que j'ai dit en effet toute cette
j'allais dire cette dérive n'est pas une
dérive mais toute cette évolution d'eric
zemmour de journaliste politique à
hommes politiques elle venait de trouver
sa conclusion et je n'imaginais plus une
seconde qu au mois de mars il commentera
la présidentielle j'étais sûr qu'il en
serait un acteur j'avais pas lui dire
vas-y n'y va pas je lui dis que je
comprends ton raisonnement est ce que
c'est votre ami reg des mots on l'a
entendu avec aymeric caron il ya un
instant voilà il ya beaucoup de gens qui
vous disent que vous pouvez être ami
avec un quelqu'un qui parce que c'est
vrai qu'éric on en a parlé de thaler
quelqu'un que beaucoup de gens
considèrent comme raciste ou à l'extrême
droite bon d'abord il n'est pas raciste
voilà donc c'est ça qu'on aimerait
savoir vous non je connais eric zemmour
depuis 15 ans je vous dise droit dans
les yeux cyril hanouna comme on dit dans
le débat présidentiel télévisé eric
zemmour n'est pas raciste et ensuite
l'amitié avec quelqu'un dont on ne
partage pas toutes les opinions
c'est une expérience qu'on fait ou que
font des millions de français ça arrive
tous les jours dans la vie vous est
copain avec quelqu'un qui n'a pas vos
idées et je trouverais que l' inverse
serait inquiétant et un peu triste ton
nez dans ses relations que des gens avec
lesquels vous êtes parfaitement d'accord
à propos de quoi est-ce qu'on semblerait
à table par exemple eric zemmour c'est
vous qui l'avait invité au meeting vous
personnellement qu'il vous l'avez
l'invité de luis attaque je les invite
et bien sûr et je lui ai dit 'si mais il
avait le droit de ne pas venir ouais si
je suis pas venu vous ça vous aurait
baissé
en janvier était fâché avec lui non
fâché non non rien ne peut me fâcher
avec eric vraiment mais je tenais
vraiment à des singes aurait été
attristé c'est pas pareil voyez nous
soigner dit quoi mon ami vient pas
soutenir dans un moment aussi important
ouais je me serais dit ça donc il vous
est de venir donc il est venu en tant
qu'ami voilà ils auraient raison de
l'argentin journée là pour représenter
en camion en tant que journaliste eric
je suis venu en tant que chroniqueur oui
ma présence ici je peux commenter de
vive voix ce que j'ai vu à villepinte et
je suis venu en tant qu'ami mais ce que
vient directement est important eric
zemmour fait partie non seulement de mes
amis mais mes plus proches d'amis un ami
proche c'est quelqu'un qui on peut tout
dire et duquel on peut tout entendre et
vous lui dites tout je lui dis tout il
me dit où j'ai été là dans des moments
importants de la vie d'eric zemmour dans
lesquels je n'entre pas puisque c'est
d'eux s'est à moitié privée à moitié
publique et il était là aussi dans des
moments importants de ma vie j'estime
que villepinte était un moment très
important dans la vie des règlements je
suis venu lui apporter mon témoignage
amical et au passage je peux vous dire
qu'en tant qu'observateurs politique
j'ai ramassé d'état d'observation qui me
sont utiles pour mon travail ici comme à
touche pas à mon poste colonial qui a
remplacé zemmour et naulleau qui
s'appellerait sont celles dont vous
étiez en tant que n'étaient pas là en
tant que soutien vous étiez l'entente
qu'a mis à part en tant que soutien
alors pas du tout je vous ai dit la
liste de mes désaccords note exhaustif
pour que je sois un soutien d'eric
zemmour il faudrait que lui comme moi on
renonce à des convictions très profonde
or nous sommes des hommes de conviction
donc nous restons sur nos désaccords et
nous restons je parle pour moi mais je
pense que zemmour appuiera cette
définition je reste sur mon amitié avec
les règlements et eric zemmour mais moi
vous savez
au delà de son humour qui est pierre
graff et bien rien comme en bas
produisent et lyon spectacle non mais
c'est
moi pour moi naulleau et un est un est
un homme du xviiie siècle c'est à dire
qu'il a le talent vous savez ddd salon à
la française où on se moquait pour un
mouvement on pouvait tuer d'un
épigrammes moi je je je rêve de ça
depuis mon adolescence
et j'ai trouvé en eau l'eau quelqu'un
qui incarne pour moi cet esprit là voilà
ça c'est vraiment ce que j'aime le plus
chez lui maintenant moi j'aime les
désaccords c'est ça qu'on ne comprend
pas c'est à dire que pour moi le plaisir
de la discussion de la controverse est
supérieur à beaucoup de choses mais je
vous comprenez j'aime tant désaccord
parce que ça nourrit en eau l'eau me
fait des réflexions quand d'autres le
font de réflexion et qu'on n'est pas
d'accord ça m'intéresse ça me nourrit
mais sam enrichit donc vous comprenez
c'est ça c'était important il ya une
phrase célèbre de trousses qui dit
l'amitié ce n'est pas l'accord des
opinions mais c'est la continuité des
esprits nous avons des esprits
continuent nous n'avons pas des opinions
accordé eric eric naulleau quand on vous
dit qu'eric zemmour est un fréquentes à
vous dites quoi non c'est tout le
contraire si on parle une maintenant
effectivement il est plus que fréquente
atteint compagnon très agréable
politiquement c'est le représentant
d'une droite
authentique un peu à l'ancienne il a
parlé de gaulle au bonapartisme moi je
suis le représentant d'une gauche un peu
à l'ancienne qui luttent contre la
gauche nouvelle la gauche walk moi je
suis partisan représentant de la gauche
laïque républicaine antitotalitaire
c'est pas celle qui est sur le devant de
la scène mais bon on va laisser passer
notre tour pour la prochaine
présidentielle
donc on verra en 2025 eric naulleau pour
nos téléspectateurs qui n'ont l'air
d'être toujours de gauche mais moi je
suis j'ai toujours été de gauche et je
serai toujours de gauche mais pas de
noter aller voter vidal gauche et
botanique algo alors je vais voter dans
le secret de l'isoloir et je ne vous
répondrai ni sur un hidalgo ni sur eric
zemmour et 3% sur jean luc mélenchon
ne répondrai à cette question ni à la
même question à prendre si vous êtes de
gauche jean-luc mélenchon a dit d'algues
ont bien yannick jadot peut-être voilà
écolo vous voyez on a le choix de
joujoux tiendra au sein des trois je
vous tiendrai au courant chaud mais je
suis décidée je vous envoie